free will in a meaningful sense is
having a degree of control and agency
and that is always a matter of degree
it's not you have it or you don't right
[Music]
I suppose for example we had an
experiment
um or rather some kind of finding
whereby some scientists has developed
the technology to predict with 100
certainty they scan somebody's brain
they track every single position of
every atom in the brain and which
direction neurons are firing and all of
this kind of thing and they're able with
some computer program to predict with
100 accuracy exactly what a human being
will do over the next five minutes and
every time they run it it predicts it
with 100 accuracy is this the kind of
thing that would make you skeptical that
people are free it would I think that
that thought is always quite scary to
people isn't it we don't like to think
we're that predictable but
predictability is in a sense a bit of a
red herring there it's a bit like the
idea you know it's a third theological
argument that um if God God knows what
you're going to do before you've even
done it then how can your actions be
free right because the idea here seems
to be that if it's predictable it's
somehow you know fixed in the wrong kind
of way but
um sometimes I I make predictable free
choices all the time right so if you see
me going to order a coffee and you know
what kind of coffee I like I don't
literally order the same one every time
but you'll probably be able to predict
what I'm going to order you're certainly
going to predict I'm not going to order
a caramel latte Grande Maximo whatever
it's called
um that's very very predictable it's
entirely predictable but why does that
mean it's not free in fact the reason
it's freeze is because I mean Hume
argued that it's the predictability
which shows you it's free as if you like
that it's because my choices are driven
by my my desires my personality and
these things have a meaningful stability
that's what makes the choice of the
coffee meaningful and that in turn is
what makes it somewhat predictable so I
I don't I don't think we should get to
sort of concern that predictability is
in itself the big threat to Free Will
Peter do you agree with Julian on this
if we have this computer that can
predict I could I could I could write
down on a bit of paper right now every
word that you're about to say and answer
this question and once you've said it I
turned it around and said I predicted it
with 100 accuracy would that be
traveling to you
[Laughter]
a little disconcerting uh I agree but
but
I agree more with Julian that
predictability uh and freedom don't have
a particularly antagonistic relationship
between the coffee example I accept I
think the sorts of things that are
scientifically
uh in principle showable that would
really be destabilizing or undermining a
free will would be work on the mechanics
that showed that the kind of belief
desire interaction that on the milder
conceptions of free choice is what has
to underlie a free Behavior you know you
want this you believe this this action
makes sense in terms of your police and
you desires so you do that if that's the
model of an unconstrained
reasonable free choice
if it turns out that lots of what
actually generates our behavior is quite
different from that
and the thing that we think of as the
belief desire story that might be told
is a kind of confabulated
rationalization we're just storytelling
when we engage in those sorts of
interpretations
if that's showable then I'm bothered
as we're talking here remembering
experiment I I read about years ago I
don't know if this has been followed up
I think it's called the pantyhose
experiment uh this was from some decades
ago where the idea was there are certain
kinds of predictability in people's
product choices if you line things up on
a table I think it's a right hand
preference or something like that people
reliably go for a particular the object
in a particular part of the display
and you can do an experiment with the
four items in the display are physically
identical
they'll go for a particular one pretty
reliably and you ask them why and
they'll cook up a story they'll find it
we'll say Oh I thought that one just had
a nicer texture or it just the the
particular color appealed to me even
though the experimenter is quite
confident that there's no physical
difference between these things so
that's a situation where there's a
disconnect between the store the the
rationalizing story that the person has
in their mind
either before the fact or after the fact
or both
and the mechanics behind the actual
thing they did
now if there was tons of that if that
was something that was all over Human
Action where it's not predictability per
se it's the fact that what predicts the
choice is something that's far outside
of what looks like the kind of
rationalizing belief desire based story
if that was all over the place I would
be more than disconcerted I think that
really would be that would be trouble as
scientists and we off we see self-report
as notoriously unreliable like we as a
neuroscientist I like including
self-report variables in my experiments
often because I find it fascinating how
they don't necessarily align up with um
how confidence doesn't severally line up
with action and you get these lovely
divergences and and yes we do create
narratives after the fact and there is a
reason why um self-report measures
deviate from uh actual mapping of a
neural and physiological measures and
you see that more for self-related
Concepts than you do for extra receptive
so we have the X receptor system which
is how to navigate and understand the
world we have the Interceptor system
which is how to understand ourselves
um and our internal signals and you can
do experiments where you look at
people's
ability to be confident that they've
seen felt heard an extra sepsis
signal and that nicely corresponds to
confidence you get a nice confidence
accuracy correspondence but with
Interceptor signals about what's
happening in our cells you get this
massive Divergence between confidence
and accuracy for self-related signals
and that's potentially because there's
been a Divergence in our extra sector
signals have helped us navigate the
world whereas we're constantly bombarded
by signals in our body to our brains all
the time and we don't necessarily want
to be aware of them influence them by
them unless they've reached a threshold
of hunger and other types of
homeostatic needs so you do get this
potential Divergence between the the
Interceptor signal and conscious access
it's my recollection of that older
experiment with the display is that
accurate yeah yeah I've heard I've heard
that vague one which is absolutely
people will narrate things afterwards
yeah but I want to say about that was
that yeah sure we we do confabulate we
do create these stories absolutely and
and we underestimate how much of our
choices are like that but the thing
about these experiments right is that
people go oh my God this is
extraordinary just because it's to the
right these experiments are usually
around things which are like trivial or
unimportant or marginal right so you
know even the libit thing you know press
a button for no good reason whatsoever
at any time right how and and that
experiment is meant to tell you about
whether you have free will about you
know the person you choose to have your
children with or or stuff like that
pantyhose oh so people will choose the
pantyhose to the right rather than this
do people go into the shops and we need
to buy pantyhose and walk out with socks
because the display no they don't right
so I I think that so often the problem
here one of the problems here is that
it's very very easy to show that we're
swayable and persuadable by things we're
not aware of but the experimenters tend
to be several things are more important
things so let's take something more
serious voting right I think there is
some evidence that
um the order of the candidates on the
ballot paper has that has a
statistically significant effect on how
many votes they have but but that does
not mean that 99 90 people are going
there know who they want to vote for
they find the candidate and they cross
it what's happening is the sort of like
10 of people who are just undecided or
not very thoughtful go in and a
percentage of them are influenced by the
position on the ballot paper and if you
statistically analyze it that turns out
to be significant it tells you it
doesn't tell you that most people going
into vote aren't voting for someone who
they've chosen to vote for because that
candidate they believe most of lines
with their values so you know
generalizing from these very very
contrived laboratory experiments to the
big important decisions on life is is um
is a huge loop as an experimentalist I
completely agree with that like uh we
need to have these things in the lab in
order to study them but I absolutely
believe they're contrived as well and we
can exercise there's different circuitry
that underlies this automatic type
processing and more controlled
processing like the prefrontal cortex
sizes inhibitory control over these more
automatic signals so absolutely
it's hard to investigate consequential
choices in an experiment because you
don't want too much to depend on the
downstream consequences of what you do
in an experiment yeah we're limited yeah
this kind of uh Insight shows us you
know the idea that there's a somewhat
statistically reliable indicator of
voting based on the order of candidates
on on a form and this isn't enough to
determine that somebody will always vote
for the first person but it's it's one
of a great deal of influencing factors
but let's say we just started to
consider what the other influencing
factors are so the fact that the first
name on the on the ballot uh that's not
enough to determine somebody voting but
it has a small influence in that
direction so why someone who does tick
that name why else might they take that
name well maybe because of their
upbringing and the kind of political uh
culture that they're born into
they have no control over that that's
quite a big influence over who they vote
over maybe they watched a television
debate and they and someone did
particularly well
and and maybe like they didn't control
whether the TV was on or they walked
home and the show happened to be on
maybe their parents were watching it or
something like this you know
if you consider all of these kinds of
factors and we we discovered that the
majority or even all of the factors when
you consider all of them are the kinds
of things like the order of the the
ballot that we just don't have control
over but it turns out that it's things
of that kind which overall do in fact
determine ultimately why the person uh
ticked that box there might be lots of
different factors but if we're equally
not in control of any of those factors
can we really say that we're in control
of who we take
to continue watching this video click
the link in the top left or in the
description below or visit iai.tv for
more debates and talks from the world's
leading thinkers on today's biggest
ideas